HIS SON?
HERE WITH MORE REACTION, SENATE
JUDICIARY CHAIRMAN,
LINDSEY GRAHAM.
I DON'T KNOW.
I THINK THAT IF I FLEW TO CHINA
AND I HAD NO EXPERIENCE IN
PRIVATE EQUITY AND I GOT A DEAL,
I WOULD BE PRETTY HAPPY, BUT IT
DOESN'T LOOK GOOD, DOES IT.
>> Linsday: WELL, YOU KNOW,
WE'VE LOOKED AT THE TRUMP
FAMILY.
IT'S ABOUT TIME SOMEBODY LOOK AT
THE CONNECTIONS OF THE UKRAINE.
HERE'S MY QUESTION.
WHEN THE VICE PRESIDENT TOLD THE
UKRAINE WE WILL TAKE THE MONEY
AWAY FROM YOU UNLESS YOU FIRE
THE PROSECUTOR, DID HE HAVE A
CONFLICT OF INTEREST BECAUSE
THEY WERE LOOKING AT HIS SON?
TOMORROW, WE WILL READ THE
TRANSCRIPT.
IS THERE ANY EVIDENCE AT ALL
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP THREATENED
TO TAKE AID AWAY.
I DON'T KNOW, BUT I WILL TELL
YOU THIS.
THE ANSWER IS, YES.
I WILL BE ON YOUR SHOW VERY
DISAPPOINTED WITH OUR PRESIDENT.
IF THE ANSWER IS NO, THIS IS
RUSSIA TIMES TO TIMES TEN.
>> Sean: DO YOU SEE EVEN JUST
THE RUSH TO JUDGMENT?
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT'S HERE.
WE DO KNOW THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
HAD THAT SO-CALLED
"WHISTLE-BLOWER" POLITICAL
AGENDA.
THEY DON'T KNOW ANY OF THE
FACTS.
DETAILS.
DONALD TRUMP IS GOING TO RELEASE
HIS TRANSCRIPTS WITH UKRAINE.
I'D LIKE TO RELEASE JOE BIDEN'S
CONVERSATIONS WITH LEADERS WHEN
HE WAS VICE PRESIDENT AND MAY BE
BARACK OBAMA'S AS WELL.
IS THAT FAIR?
>> Lindsey: YEAH, I THINK IT'S
VERY FAIR.
WHO TOLD HIM OR HER ABOUT IT?
SEE TOO WELL, THAT'S
>> Lindsey: LET ME TELL YOU.
SOMEBODY TOLD THIS PERSON ABOUT
A PHONE CALL.
DID THEY HAVE A POLITICAL AGEND
AGENDA?
I WILL MAKE AN OFFER ON
TELEVISION.
IF YOU WANT TO TESTIFY UNDER
OATH TO THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE,
YOU ARE WELCOME TO DO SO.
I WANT TO FIND THE TRUTH.
HERE'S ANOTHER QUESTION.
WAS THERE A REASON TO WITHHOLD
AID TO THIS UKRAINIAN
ADMINISTRATION?
WAS IT OKAY FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP
TO WITHHOLD MONEY TO TRY TO GET
OTHER COUNTRIES TO GIVE MORE?
THESE ARE THE QUESTIONS THAT
SOMEBODY NEEDS TO ASK AND
ANSWER.
>> Sean: SENATOR, IS THIS GOOD
POLITICALLY SPEAKING?
HOW DO YOU THINK THIS PLAYS OUT
FOR THE DEMOCRATS?
>> Lindsey: WELL, IT TELLS ME
THAT THEY THINK THEY ARE GOING
TO LOSE AT THE BALLOT BOX.
THE ONLY REASON THEY ARE TRYING
TO IMPEACH THE PRESIDENT IS
BECAUSE THEY DON'T BELIEVE THEY
CAN BEAT HIM AT THE BALLOT BOX
SO THEY ARE TRYING TO DESTROY
IT.
IT COMES ONTO THIS.
IF THERE IS NO EVIDENCE THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP TRIED TO COERCE
THE UKRAINIAN INTO INVESTIGATING
BIDEN AND WITHHOLDING AID, THEN
THERE'S NOTHING HERE.
THAT WILL BE THE ONLY THING THAT
WOULD BOTHER ME.
IT WOULD BE OKAY FOR THE
PRESIDENT TO TELL THE
UKRAINIANS, HEY, IF HE WAS FIRED
FOR A PURPOSE, MAYBE YOU SHOULD
LOOK AT IT.
>> Sean: HOW DO YOU GET TO A
POINT WERE DEMOCRATS, CRAZY NEW
GREEN DEAL, $36 TRILLION, SOME
ESTIMATES, $94 TRILLION FOR THE
NEW GREEN DEAL.
THEY WANT TO STACK THE U.S.
SUPREME COURT.
THEY WANT TO GET RID OF THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE.
IT SEEMS THAT THIS PARTY HAS
LOST ANY SENSE OF CONSTITUTIONAL
GOVERNMENTS.
THE ENUMERATED POWERS OF
COMMANDER AND CHIEF LIE WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
HOW DOES THE
PRESIDENT EFFECTIVELY BE THE
COMMANDER AND CHIEF IF HIS PHONE
CALLS ARE BEING SPIED ON AND
LEAKS ARE COMING OUT FOR PEOPLE
THAT HAVE POLITICAL AGENDAS.
IF THIS IS SECONDHAND
INFORMATION, WHERE DID IT COME
FROM AND HOW IS IT THAT THEY GOT
SO MUCH WRONG IT ALREADY?
>> Lindsey: I THINK WHAT WE
WANT TO KNOW IS IF THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER IS TELLING US
SOMETHING THAT THEY KNOW TO BE
TRUE FIRSTHAND, REPEATING GOSSIP
GIVEN TO THEM BY SOMEBODY ELSE.
BUT HERE'S WHAT TRUMP HAS DONE
THAT SO IMPORTANT.
YOU CAN READ IT FOR YOURSELF
TOMORROW.
THE ONE THING ABOUT THIS
PRESIDENT THAT I ADMIRE IS THAT
HE IS RELEASING A PHONE CALL
THAT YOU CAN MAKE YOUR OWN
JUDGMENT.
IF THERE IS NO EVIDENCE THAT
DONALD TRUMP TRIED TO WITHHOLD
MILITARY AID, THERE'S NOTHING
HERE.
BUT THERE'S A LOT HERE WHEN IT
COMES TO BIDEN.
DID HE HAVE A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST WHEN HE THREATENED TO
WITHHOLD AID TO THE UKRAINE?
THAT NEEDS TO BE LOOKED AT.
WAS THERE A REASON TO WITHHOLD
AFTER THE SELECTION APART FROM
BIDEN?
A LOT OF PEOPLE WERE WORRIED
ABOUT THIS NEW ADMINISTRATION.
SHOULD WE >> Sean: LET M
SHOULD WE >> Sean: LET E
SHOULD WE >> Sean: LET A
SHOULD WE >> Sean: LET K
SHOULD WE >> Sean: LET Y
SHOULD WE >> Sean: LET U
SHOULD WE >> Sean: LET T
SHOULD WE >> Sean: LET I
SHOULD WE >> Sean: LET .
IF WE ARE AT A POINT HERE WHERE
THIS IS WHAT WE ARE GOING TO DO
IS WE ARE NOW GOING TO SPY ON
PRESIDENTS, I DON'T KNOW WHERE
THIS ALL ENDS UP, IS AMERICA
SAFE BECAUSE OF THIS?
>> Lindsey: AMERICA IS FAR
LESS SAFE WHEN A WHISTLE-BLOWER
FILES A COMPLAINT WHEN THEY WERE
NOT A PART OF THE PHONE CALL.
IF THE DEMOCRATIC THREATENED TO
WITHHOLD AID TO A FOREIGN
COUNTRY UNLESS A PROSECUTOR IS
LOOKING AT HIS SON AND NOTHING
HAPPENS AND THEY ARE WILLING TO
IMPEACH PRESIDENT TRUMP ON A
PHONE CALL THEY KNOW NOTHING
ABOUT.
>> Sean: LAST QUESTION.
COULD YOU IMAGINE ANY SCENARIO
UNDER WHICH A VICE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES WITHHOLDS
$1 BILLION.
I'M NOT GOING TO HAVE IT TO YOU
UNLESS YOU FIRE A UKRAINIAN
PROSECUTOR?
>> Lindsey: IT REAL QUICK.
WHAT IF MIKE PENCE CALLS
SOMEBODY TOMORROW AND THREATENS